[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich Willkommen an diesem
Sonntag abend Fußball und Football gibt
V ruderne ja nachher mehr dazu schönen
guten Abend schauen wir auf die großen
Themen
heute was tun gegen das Leid während die
Kämpfe im gazerstreifen Weitergehen
suchen der US Außenminister und der
Palästinenserpräsident eine
diplomatische Lösung
Ende einer Geiselnahme 18 Stunden
Ausnahmezustand am Hamburger Flughafen
dann lässt ein Vater seine eigene
Tochter frei und ergibt
sich ein Ei zwei Teams viel Kommerz in
Frankfurt steigt das Spitzenspiel der
amerikanischen Football League die sich
davon mehr Fans in übe
verspricht seit fast vi Wochen sind die
rund 24 in den Händen der terrormiliz
Hamas um die Bedingungen für mögliche
Freilassungen von Geiseln zu verbessern
und humanitäre Unterstützung nach Gaza
zu bringen hat sich usaußenminister
blinken für eine vorübergehende
Feuerpause ausgesprochen erst derzeit im
Nahen Osten über die aktuelle Kriegslage
berichtet Henriette
deier Schritt für Schritt dringen
israelische Soldaten tiefer in den
Gazastreifen vor Bilder des israelischen
Militärs die den Erfolg zeigen sollen
auch die Angriffe aus der Luft gehen
weiter unser Team in Gaza filmte heute
diese Bilder laut Angaben der Hamas
starben in der vergangenen Nacht
mindestens 38 Menschen bei einem Angriff
auf ein
flüchtlingsviertel weitermachen bis wir
sie besiegen beschwor israels
Ministerpräsident netanahu heute
Soldaten bei einem Truppenbesuch er
sagte wir haben keine Wahl ich möchte
euch eindeutig sagen was wir nicht tun
werden es wird keine Waffenpause geben
ohne die Rückkehr der führten das kann
man gleich streichen wir sagen das
sowohl unseren Feinden als auch unseren
Freunden und spielt damit auf US
Außenminister blinken an der heute in
ramala war und mit Palästinenser
Präsident Abbas zusammentraf Abbas
fordert eine sofortige Waffenruhe
blinken lehnt dies als Stärkung der
Hamas ab setzt sich für örtlich
begrenzte Kampfpausen
ein währenddessen protestierenen ramala
die Menschen werfen den USA vor Israel
blind zu unterstützen
heute ist die Botschaft des
palästinensischen Volkes völlig klar
unser gesamtes Volk steht standhaft mit
Widerstand und im Kampf gegen den
völkermordkrieg der durch die
israelische Besatzung und mit
Unterstützung der amerikanischen
Regierung geführt wird US Außenminister
blinken reiste am Abend weiter in die
Türkei Diplomatie im engen
Takt weltweit sind hunderttausende bei
proalästinensischen Demonstrationen auf
die Straße gegangen
in Washington forderten gestern Zeus
eine sofortige Waffenruhe und die USA
sollten die Hilfszahlungen an Israel
einstellen in Griechenland zogen
demonstrierende heute vor das Parlament
in Athen und in Jakarta in Indonesien
verlangten hunderttausende ein Ende der
israelischen Angriffe auch hochrangige
Politiker nahmen an der Kundgebung
teil aber auch aus Solidarität mit
Israel sind heute wieder Menschen auf
die Straße gegangen in Berlin nah nach
polizeieingaben etwa 450 Menschen an
einem Demonstrationszug Teil sie
erinnerten an den Überfall vor einem
Monat bei dem hamasterroristen
mindestens 1400 Menschen gefoltert und
getötet sowie rund 240 weitere entführt
hatten die Geiselnahme am Hamburger
Flughafen ist beendet nach 18 Stunden
hat er 35jährige Geiselnehmer aufgegeben
hintergrund ist offenbar ein
Sorgerechtsstreit der bewaffnete Mann
war gestern Abend mit seinem Auto und
seiner vierjährigen Tochter auf das
Vorfeld des Flughafens gerast der
Flugbetrieb wurde komplett eingestellt
Steffen Wachs mit den
Einzelheiten der Vater verlässt den
Wagen nach mehr als 18 Stunden zusammen
mit der vierjährigen Tochter ihre Mutter
wartet bereits im Terminal die Polizei
hatte ständig Sichtkontakt und
kommunizierte über ein Handy mit dem
35-Jährigen im Auto ja das Kind ist von
uns in ophut genommen worden und den
ersten Eindruck den wir jetzt hatten ist
dass das Kind ganz gut drauf
gestern Abend durchbricht der Mann ein
Tor zum Rollfeld des Flughafens wirft
Brandsätze schießt mehrmals mit einer
Waffe in die Luft und rast in die Nähe
einer Maschine die gerade starten sollte
die Menschen mussten in den Flugzeugen
bleiben oder die Terminals verlassen
dann wurden wir zurückgerufen saßen da
irgendwie zweieinhalb Stunden oder dre
im Flieger 5 Minuten vor Abflug sofort
alle raus Flughfen verlassen
wahrscheinlich läuft heute gar nichts
mehr wir müssen wahrscheinlich die Nacht
heute hier bleiben der gesamte Flughafen
wird evakuiert reisende müssen in Hotels
übernachten der Grund für die Entführung
offenbar ein Sorgerechtsstreit der Vater
forderte in die Türkei ausgeflogen zu
werden schon einmal so die Polizei habe
er sich mehrere Monate mit seiner
Tochter unerlaubt in der Türkei
aufgehalten warum er es geschafft hat
auf das Rollfeld zu gelangen werden
Flughafen und Bundespolizei nun klären
müssen wirfüllen die technischen
Vorgaben und auch die gesetzlichen
Vorgaben und nun werden wir natürlich
mit den Behörden mit den zuständigen
sicherheitsmenschen vor Ort auch noch
mal schauen was muss eventuell angepasst
werden
hier sollten heute 286 Maschinen starten
und landen die Terminals sind wieder
offen es werde aber noch zu erheblichen
Streichungen und Verzögerungen im
Flugbetrieb
kommen mit großer Spannung wird das
Treffen morgen in Berlin von den
ministerpräsidentinnen und Präsidenten
mit dem Kanzler erwartet dabei wird es
vor allem um den Umgang mit geflüchteten
sowie die Migrationspolitik gehen die
Bundesländer pochen auf mehr Geld vom
Bund und sie wollen das weniger
geflüchtete nach Deutschland kommen mehr
von Andreas
hupert Flucht übers Mittelmeer die Zahl
der Bote sie will nicht abreisen
italienische Insel Lampedusa an diesem
Wochenende wiederkommen Flüchtlinge zu
Dutzenden aus Afrika und Asien ihr Ziel
Europa es kommen mehr als im letzten
Jahr es sterben mehr als im letzten Jahr
es liegt nicht an den Seenotrettern
sondern daran dass wir keine Einigungen
mit afrikanischen Staaten haben und
daher brauchen wir sichere
drittstaatslösungen ohne Einigungen mit
afrikanis Staaten ist die Zahl der
kommenden nicht zu reduzieren auch in
Deutschland steigt die Zahl der
Flüchtlinge stetig schon längst schlagen
Städte Kommunen und die Länder
Alarm wir erwarten uns jetzt den
nächsten Schritte von der
Bundesregierung das ist die Beteiligung
an den finanziellen Lasten die die
Zuwanderung und die Migration mit sich
bringt und die insbesondere bei der
kommunalen Familie aufschlägt deshalb
haben die Bundesländer in ihren
Forderungskatalog an den Kanzler
konkrete Zahlen hineingeschrieben sie
fordern eine Pauschale von 1,25
Milliarden Euro pro Jahr plus 10500 €
für jeden Flüchtling außerdem sollen
verschärfte Grenzkontrollen
beschleunigte Asylverfahren und
konsequentere Abschiebungen die Zahl der
Flüchtlinge in und nach Deutschland
begrenzen auch künftig statt
bargeldleistungen Sachleistungen zu
gewähren wird diskutiert von
bargeldleistung auf Sachleistung
umzustellen das gibt es schon seit
einiger Zeit das können die Länder die
Landkreise machen und ich ich bin dafür
dass da morgen ganz pragmatisch drüber
geredet wird ob man das ganze ausweiten
kann und sogar zu bundeseinheitlichen
Modellen kommen morgen ab 15 Uhr im
Kanzleramt das bundländertreffen auf der
Suche nach Lösungen beim großen
Streitthema
Migration und das ganzinterview mit SPD
Chef klingbei gleich nach uns in Berlin
direkt nach Nepal dort mussten nach dem
schweren Erdbeben am Freitagabend
tausende Menschen die zweite Nacht bei
bitterer Kälte im Freien verbringen
internationale Hilfsorganisation
kündigten derweil ihre Unterstützung für
die Überlebenden an bei dem Beben waren
mindestens 157 Menschen ums Leben
gekommen mehr 100 wurden verletzt viele
Gebäude waren durch das Erdbeben
eingestürzt erneut haben schwere
Unwetter die mittelitalienische Region
tosana heim gesucht nach stürmen und
heftigen Regenfällen in der Nacht sind
weite Gebiete überflutet in mehr als
16000 Haushalten gibt es keine Strom
einige Dörfer mussten evakuiert werden
seit Donnerstag sind bei den Unwettern
in der Region mindestens sieben Menschen
ums Leben
gekommen und jetzt kommen wir zum Sport
0 Z4 verloren im eigenen Stadion
borussia Dortmund ist von den Bayen ja
ziemlich wirklich überrumpelt worden
absolut sowas nennt man gern mal eine
Lehrstunde mit Haar natürlich es war
eine Machtdemonstration mit der Borussia
Dortmund regelrecht gedemütigt wurde
Mann des Abends bei dieser bayernala war
mal wieder Harry Kane der gleich dreimal
tr
zum dritten Mal in dieser
Saison das 134 Duell von FCB und BVB
eines der einseitigsten jemals mit einem
unersätlichen Harry Kane der
Führungstreffer bereits nach 3 Minuten
Ecke San und upamano per Kopf Bayern
legt nach 8 Minuten gespielt Goretzka
mit Ball und San schneller als die
Schwarzgelben Harry Kane zum
2:0 Reus mit Dortmunds bester Chance
nach der Pause trefficher die Bayern
Harry Kane ganz allein mit seinem
zweiten und dritten Treffer der
Matchwinner beim klaren 4:0 Sieg der
Engländer mit 15 Treffer nach Z spielen
bester Torschütze der
Liga Erfolg auch für die Frauen des FC
Bayern München nach einem knappen Sieg
im Topspiel konnten sie die
Tabellenführung erobern die Meisterinnen
setzten sich mit 2:1 gegen die DFB
pokalsiegerinnen vom VfL Wolfsburg durch
und das gibt's nicht so oft die National
Football League hat ein Gastspiel in
Deutschland in Frankfurt am Main trat
der Super Bowl Champion Kansas City
Chiefs gegen die Miami Dolphins an
Kansas gewann die Partie mit 21 Z 14 und
schon vor dem Spiel war der Hype
gigantisch Frankfurt im Football Fieber
schon Stunden vor dem Spiel was die
Kostümierungen anbetrifft steht es
unentschieden zwischen den Miami
Dolphins und den Kansas City Chiefs ich
war so glücklich dass ich Tickets
bekommen habe und da habe ich gesagt
Mensch mit meiner Freundin unterstütze
ich beide Teams dass wir das hier in
Deutschland haben dürfen ist große Ehre
mittendrin Superstar Patrick mahomes der
Quarterback von Kansas City überragend
startet sein Team der Super Bowl
Champion ein unglaublicher Lauf von
Brian Cook der dritte Touchdown bringt
die 21:0 Führung zur Pause das Stadion
BT im dritten Viertel wird es wieder
spannen Touchdown Rahim mostard Miami
verkürzt auf 14:21 am Ende aber
triumphieren die Kansas City Chiefs in
Frankfurt ja da ging's zur Sache das
war's danke schön Rudi blicken wir auf
die wetteraussicht
im Südosten länger sonnig sonst
wechselnd bewölkt im Norden später auch
im Südwesten häufiger Schauer örtlich
Gewitter lebhafter Südwestwind an der
See und im Bergland mit stürmischen
Böhen 9 bis
14° um 21:2 läuft das heute journal mit
Christian sieers wir sehen uns morgen
wieder und jetzt übergebe ich an
shakunal benegi mit Berlin direkt